now here to discuss kayleigh mcinerney
co-host
of outnumbered and former white house
press secretary of course
and karl rove fox news contributor you
know both of you
have uh extraordinary access you've both
been in the white house you've both been
advising and working with the the top
tier of power the pres presidents of the
united states
uh it is uh important to recognize i
think that this is a gigantic system
what is your take kaylee let me ask you
do you think
i'm going too far in my assessment here
it seems like
the average person has gotten lost in a
machine now that just doesn't care
i think you're spot on look president
obama recently
said that president joe biden is
finishing what i started but let's not
forget what president obama started
ended in the presidency of president
donald trump and
when he looked at exit polling through
the primaries one poll always stuck out
to me and this was the 2016 primaries
and it was this they felt betrayed by
the federal government that was
at a record high and in blue states in
fact the betrayal of the federal
government metric was
close to 50 in some blue states and that
existed for a very specific reason
americans were left behind
and by contrast when you got to 2019
pre-pandemic and president trump you saw
the largest annual gains in median
household income on record
groups that have been traditionally left
behind black americans hispanic
americans disproportionately saw those
gains
poverty at a at a low going back to 1959
the results were there and i think
doubling down on the obama policies
is a real risk for president joe biden
even if he doesn't see it now
you know it's fascinating carl great to
see you if this is
a perfect juxtaposition though the
shocking success economically of donald
trump
that we were told could never happen
that this is just you know new normals
and it's just the global thing and this
is what happens
and suddenly there was proof that wait a
minute one person can make the
difference
when you think about the nature of
what's happening and i know
numbers are your thing and and the facts
of the matter with what goes back to
legislation and everything else
but this is a real personal reaction by
the american people
to what's happening in government right
now yeah i think it's very personal in
large part
because they were misled there was no
mandate created for this by a campaign
in 2020 that said
elect joe biden president he's going to
ask for six trillion dollars to be added
to the deficit he's gonna
call for a huge expansion of federal
power and the government is going to
take over
everything from running your elections
to determining what kind of car you
drive
to what your kids learned in school and
so forth none of that was done during
the campaign
very simple message during the campaign
joe biden is not donald trump and donald
trump is screwing up covent so part of
the reaction that i think is starting
and we're going to see more of it
as as ordinary americans say wait a
minute you didn't tell me about this
and and the smugness of the elites in
the academia
in the unions in the media in part of
big business
and in the government in the think tanks
this this is going to grow
the the animosity of the ordinary people
is going to grow in the months ahead
we have an example of how the average
people are reacting kaylie both of you
listen but kay i'm going to want to get
your reaction to this
viewers calling out brian stelter uh on
c-span in a call-in show listen to this
yes i'd like to ask brian to
on national television admit he
and his network are a bunch of liars
about donald trump
this is kevin in princeton indiana good
morning
yeah mr stelcher is the biggest
minister of misinformation i have ever
heard and i'm a
news junkie he made the statement just a
few minutes ago that he is
all the stories are always evolving yeah
his stories absolutely evolve
brian stelter thank you for the feedback
i appreciate it
savannah georgia rick good morning
you're next
uh yes i was just wondering if you still
feel like michael avenatti is the
greatest thing in the world and should
run for president of the united states
and i suggest my suggestion is whatever
cnn says do the opposite and you'll be
fine
aurora indiana this is robert good
morning you're on with brian stelter
you know cnn is just something that's
it's a joke it's a joke
this guy tells more lives and fox gives
more news than cnn does and
what why did i tell you two years it's
not about lies
well there is there it is when you don't
screen the calls regular americans call
in
kelly what's your kayla what's your take
on that what a skewering no wonder his
ratings are down 53
from january that's a perfect example of
the media elite that carl just mentioned
um you know he says what lies lies
mistrust whatever you want to call it
well one example is the ig report that
shows president trump did not clear the
path in lafayette park with tear gas
clear the path of protesters in order to
have a photo op contrary to what jim
acosta
suggested time and time again on that
network we know the russia bounty story
there were russia bounties on the
heads of american soldiers that was not
the case and they said president trump
ignored that we know
when president trump was called crazy
for saying the wuhan lab might be the
origin
for coven 19 in fact it looks like he
might have been right after all and
that's just three examples of many
there's no wonder
that now 79 of independents say that
they believe
the media makes up fake stories and
intentionally publishes them that's an
extraordinary statistic
carl we've got a few seconds here what
what's your take on him finally hearing
the reality of what people think about
what they're doing over there
i i suspect at that moment he was
thinking to himself what the heck am i
doing here
but but it's it's it's a lesson of what
under filtered television will give you
it's also a sen
it gives you a sense the ordinary
americans are
have a lot of common sense and that's
right they're they're reacting they're
the people who are paying the bill at
the grocery store and seeing prices
growing up
the people are worrying about what debt
is going to do to their kids they're the
people who say
when you talk about transformation of
our country i like our country the way
it is
and when people start talking about
wokeness it it starts to get
uh they say i'm already awake yeah and
look
the democrats are seeing that right now
and i think they're appropriately
concerned about what the future looks
like for that party
thank you both very much for joining me
tonight great stuff i appreciate it
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else